hey welcome to the new project camp
update so we bought this big piece of
land and i'm prototyping a more
sustainable way of living not sure how
it's going to go but let's see and in
the previous video you could see us
doing very specific things for instance
cleaning up this kitchen or cleaning up
a lake or cleaning up a swamp and they
are very specific tasks and they're fun
to watch because you really start from
nothing and in the end you're finished
in one video
but to be honest a lot of stuff is also
just small incremental maintenance
things not very exciting
but very crucial part of it as well so
in this video i'm going to show you a
few of these very boring but very much
needed tasks
[Music]
so the first thing we're gonna do is fix
something on this workspace because we
still have the welding machine so before
we gonna bring it back um there's a leak
on top of there but let me show you
so there's a strip here on the roof
but it got
detached um it was not in the best
condition when we got it but now it do
it's really open
so the water flows here and then it goes
between the doors and then it leaks
inside
so the water leaks from there before it
gets wet
so we're gonna clean this up and then
we're gonna weld it to make sure it's
waterproof again
[Music]
not the most beautiful fix i ever made
but should be good
it's another thing to upgrade is this
door because it always just opens itself
like the wind blows it open
but it doesn't stay like this and it can
get very noisy
with a hard wind so we have a magnet
with some rubber outside
and a m4 screw so i'm gonna put that in
the corner of the container
and then it should
hold the door
small but
comfortable upgrade
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah that's it now the container door
stays
in position
next we're gonna do some modification to
this solar box so you might have seen it
a few updates ago this is where our
solar system is running
um but as i've noticed in the youtube
comments you guys mentioned the edges
should be treated with
paint
because after we cut the water comes in
thank you very much for letting me know
makes total sense didn't think about
that so we're gonna treat them with some
paint to make sure it's really
waterproof
so let's get our paint supply
[Music]
actually don't think we have any wood
paint but we still have some black paint
left over tiny bit from painting the
frame of the solar panels
so i think we're just gonna use that
also a good reason to finish this last
bit before it dries out but before we
paint i first will make sure we're gonna
sand it a little bit so it's less porous
and it's just a nicer finish
[ __ ]
should be ready for winter now
another thing we always have to do after
using the chainsaw is to sharpen the
blades of the chain
it's quite a lot of work actually it's
like 52 of these things takes time
[Music]
so we are here at the lake
and there was a small storm that threw
down some big trees
and
we also kind of neglected a bit the lake
and as you can see there is a bit of
overgrown plants we will chop them down
[Music]
so
[Music]
next one is easy taking down the tree
that fell on my van after a big
windstorm
[Music]
and over here we have a big pile of
thorns
which is slowly
growing and taking over the base camp so
we're gonna chop it down and then we
also have some extra space and this is
actually something we're kind of always
doing here just chopping down thorns to
make sure they don't overtake a space
so yeah
but luckily we have this machine
so this is where we have to go to this
is the whole pile of dense stones
look how high these glitches are i mean
i'm quite small guys
[Music]
one tip for you guys on youtube which
makes a lot of sense it's worth
protective gear
because uh yeah it kind of gets scratchy
here in these bushes
yeah i got excited so yeah
[Music]
and this right here actually used to be
a pathway which i chopped
a few weeks ago in the update when we
cleaned the swamp
but now completely overgrown and also
the swamp itself actually down there
very bushy i guess a lot of water around
here so yeah we're gonna give this a
good haircut
look at this just oh overgrown
[Music]
so yeah this was all
bushes
and now it's not anymore so and another
task that we have to do very often is
weeding this garden
it's a very cool thing that in this
place it rains a lot there is a lot of
water and then sun and then water again
that's the perfect conditions for things
to grow
so also any kinds of weeds grow in this
garden mainly brumbles which this used
to be a big pile of brumbles and now it
has most of the herbs we've planted so
once a week we take out all of the wheat
so that to make sure that they don't
overgrow the plants we've planted
already
[Music]
so another thing we have to do quite
often while it's hot
is watering all of this garden
[Music]
and another thing which
has been taking way too long is putting
up a hammock
but the reason why it's been taking long
is that the land burned down so all big
trees are kind of gone or rotten so
the only really small trees around
like here only a few years old and
they're not really thick enough to hold
a person
so i think i'm gonna bundle a few
together and then hopefully that's
enough to
hold the hammock
[Music]
all right so these were all the
practical maintenance things we recently
did
but one other thing actually started is
to create a project camp regional map
and this is basically a map where we map
out things in the region and there are
two reasons to make this map
first reason is it might actually be
useful for you guys or anyone that is
visiting this area
to see what is to do around here because
i feel like this isn't mapped out too
much yet this area
and the other one is we're going to have
a lot of new people joining project camp
and helping out so instead of telling
them this is the store you can find this
or this is where you can get vegetables
we just have a map and everyone can
access it and easily see all the good
places
[Music]
so here's a project camp region map so
we're located in portugal around here
where let me zoom in
and the map has a lot of useful things
like where to get metal and this is a
cool place with many tubes
or this tuesday market it's good for
buying young trees
or practical stuff like a swimming pool
but not for swimming but to take a
shower
or the public library right here and
this place is always empty but the
internet is super fast
or places to wash your clothes which are
next to the supermarket so you can drink
a fresh orange juice while you wait
but besides all this practical stuff
also things to do in the weekend for
instance visit this high mountain with
snow in the winter
or visit beautiful waterfalls especially
also in winter with a lot of water
and i guess you could figure this one
out yourself on the map but yeah the
beach is there
it's a bit busy though so we also found
some beautiful close by places to swim
near the river
so yeah we have a bunch of categories
like entertainment materials foods and
the map will expand over time for
instance we still need to find scrap
yards so if you have any tips or
suggestions to see in the region let us
know
all right so that was this video very
practical one but very much needed as
well
if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
and in the next week's video i think
we're going to hook up the water which
should be exciting and very needed task
so yeah thank you very much for watching
and see you in the next video